ego is the enemy I don't like work no
man does but I like what is in the work
the chance to find yourself Joseph
Conrad for full eight years Winston
Churchill stood more or less by himself
against his short sighted peers against
the rising threat of fascism even among
the West welcome to the big show folks
sometimes that is what it takes
sometimes will be forced to go it alone
because we've alienated everyone around
us sometimes it will be because what we
believe or do is so new that there is no
other choice other times adversity will
be environmental accidental or just
temporary there is no way around it we
will experience difficulty we will feel
the touch of failure all of us exist on
this continuum we transition fluidly
along it at various points in our lives
perhaps you're born into privilege and
then aspire to something greater perhaps
are born into great difficulty or start
off on the wrong foot and then begin to
pick up the pieces or more commonly we
set out in life hoping to do great
things achieve success undermine that
success and find ourselves learning
important lessons as we seek to rebuild
and recapture but right now we're at
failure and it sucks whatever junction
more on one play dogs us ego it makes
all the steps hard and it makes failure
the hardest it leads us to failure and
then abandons us we're afraid to lose
and fail because we think it says
something about us it doesn't success
didn't either all that failure says is
that there was a chance to improve and
better understand yourself what we need
to see is that we are not failures we're
just experiencing failure where you go
next or how long you'll be here no one
can say if ego accompanies you it will
seek out failure like true north it is
its own worst enemy it is your enemy ego
is the enemy